thrilled to have elizabeth banks here on
the rich eisen show i'm susie schuster
of course in for ridgewall he is
glowing with tokyo gold and liz i'm so
happy that you came on because
he's wanted you to come on before and
i'd like to consistently
out book my husband so by the way don't
ever do the show
without me just tell rich no it's so
funny i thought the exact same thing
when you were like let's just get on and
chat this week and i thought oh man rich
is really gonna blow a gasket when he
figures out
that i came on for you and not for him
i said you know liz is calling in he's
like you're kidding i'm like yeah he's
like
i i think i've asked her a couple times
i'm like yeah she doesn't want to go on
with you
not true i love rich that's not true
what's going on with you rich it's just
worked out you know
it partially has worked out because i'm
in ireland currently as you know so i'm
eight hours ahead of you
so i'm at i'm like i'm relaxed i'm
having a glass of wine or a can of wine
and i'm
chill and normally he's like can you get
up early
during like kids school drop off and
talk to me on the podcast like no
i can't i don't know how to do that and
the answer is no
by the way i also think that having a
cocktail on hand
enhances the experience so tomorrow
um when we have you and bob costas on
having a mimosa because when i think of
bob costas i think of elizabeth banks
it's like a natural
right that's so sweet because he is like
a legend
yes um and especially with the olympics
happening
what a fun booking just so you know the
good news is this
he requested to come on with me
tokyo never just saying i mean you know
we just know wherever we know where the
bread is buttered in this family
uh okay a couple questions for you as a
mass hole
yes if you are just like me and [ __ ]
hold on
to me if you're born there you have to
know sports
or they chuck you oh yeah yeah your
earliest experience with sports as an
[ __ ]
do me playing sports or like i mean
anything knowing well i mean my dad my
dad was my softball coach and still is
an
umpire in our town he's been an um he's
been umpiring
little league and softball and high
school games for
going on 30 years he keeps threatening
to retire and he still hasn't retired so
um you know baseball was my
family's kind of first true love but
what's interesting about
where i'm from which is western
massachusetts unlike you
we live on the border of new york and
growing up the sports radio because
remember you
you know growing up you would listen to
ball games on the radio that's how you
listen to so much
back in the day and so my dad grew up
listening to
radio sports out of albany new york not
boston
and so he is actually a yankees fan
and my mom who's from boston proper is
of course
a red sox fan so i and i have two huge
ginormous families so
very much red sox yankees like
always went to fenway but also went to
yankee stadium
so i grew up with like loving daryl
strawberry
like my sister grew up loving john
mattingly right so it's like
we we play both sides my whole life so
baseball is the is sort of the thousand
primary sport in our family and then
um because my dad is was not
really a pats fan either because his
favorite player was johnny unitas oh wow
oh yeah so he is very interesting we did
a lot of college sports and my dad still
tailgates at like williams college which
i think is like division
three or something division 17. yeah
it's
not it's barely uh a blip on but he just
loves the culture of it and in western
mass like that's the
that's the best we're gonna do and then
obviously i grew up with the celtics i
grew up with the bruins
i mean you know i we have an amazing
sports
legacy where we're from as you obviously
talk about a lot on the show and
and um and then you know the patriots
uh i mean i can't it's wild what's
happened
in my adult life right
to the patriots um it's been a wild ride
but then how do you rationalize
the patriots and then of course your
husband yes the fly eagles fly guys so
who gets to who gets the teams in your
family
the boys root for who okay
well right now because we're raising
little boys in los
angeles california we are actually
trying to become a rams family
okay it's very hard going i'm not gonna
lie about it
it's not going easily it's not easy for
i'm not
there yet no i'm not sure my husband's
there yet
but you know we're trying we're going to
attempt
like we can't do dodgers and we can't do
lakers it's not going to happen my
husband's from portland oregon he's
trailblazers till death
that's all he cares about in the
portland trailblazers i got for his
birthday
this year you know we've been together a
really long time like you and rich and
it's always hard to figure out what the
best how to surprise somebody for their
birthday when you've been together this
long what's the good gift
and this year um i thought you know what
i'm gonna get damian lillard
to dm him happy birthday on instagram
that's amazing and did you get it i sure
did
yeah you did i did it and the best was
we were in different time zones when it
happened and um
and i so i so i dm sami and lillard um
i slipped into the dms on instagram and
i was like hey
this is so crazy but if i've ever made
you laugh at anything maybe you'll do me
this favor and he's like yeah girl
he really literally um dm me i got you
and he and then i woke up the next
morning
to a text from my husband max saying did
you do this
was this you what the hell happened how
does he know it's my birthday
and it was and he sent me the screen
grab
of damian lillard's happy birthday thing
and then they kind of
and then actually they went back and
forth a little bit so we actually had a
conversation with anyway that made his
life
so you know we yeah anyway we love
sports
and we're trying to do rams i know your
husband and i know he's not wanting for
anything that's the kind of thing that a
guy would get giddy about
like just get like kind of like a little
girlish about like it's different
i was thrilled that i could make it
happen for him
you know yeah as you know it's like he
has you know what do i get him he
he has me so lucky
um tell me who who was your inspiration
for gail
abernathy mchadden jewish burger yeah
um who's my inspiration you know
honestly
it we watched dodgeball and
i loved the idea it was that the snl
guys like jason sedegas doing like
commentary
um with will forte on snl right
just the idea we watched a lot of videos
of like golf commentators trying to make
things interesting and and what's
interesting here
in ireland where i am right now i just
watched
um the tennis and wimbledon
and the and bjomborg is one of the
announcers here
right so we don't we're not gifted with
that we get john mcenroe and but you
know mary
and all these people that he was
incredible just absolutely incredible
the bombs that he drops and just like
the silly nature with which he
approached the entire thing
it's it's that it's that it's that
you're a critic
of something that you actually could
never
really do and so it's about that it's
about how do you
how do you watch something and criticize
it or commentate on it
when there's no chance that you could
ever
live up to the standard that you have
set for the people that you're watching
doing the thing that you're doing and
that is absurd in and of itself
it's kind of like the olympics in a way
when we're watching all these sports
that we would never
dream in a million years of
participating in
you know with tokyo watching this on
peacock because of course we're on
peacock
we're watching all these sports that we
would never try like the 13 year old
skateboarders which by the way
are you kidding me 13 and the girls they
were amazing
kicking ass in cuffed cargos and having
their phones in their pockets and
i was watching the swimming medley last
night with
taylor and she said mom they're still
going i'm like yeah you have no idea how
much that hurts your lungs right now
oh but i i have to say summer olympics
for me are always a little bit like
i like watching like badminton and table
tennis and thinking
like i can't swim are you kidding me
like i like
i like that there's a couple sports
where like you don't have to have
a body for sports you know
you just had to have started you had to
get your 10 000 hours in
you know you had to just have like done
it there's something about
the devotion to like badminton and skeet
shooting
and things where i'm like you know what
actually like you can still eat a
cheeseburger every once in a while you
know
and do and like compete in badminton but
what
i don't know craziness what about the
craziness of the serbs on
table tennis it's really it's
it's troubling to watch they're
contorting in strange ways that don't
exist in a normal table tennis
environment
but it's the quickness of it it's how
fast it goes that is
absolutely amazing to me i mean
everything you can't
keep your eye on it i don't know how
they do it i really don't i don't think
you haven't lived if you haven't watched
rich do a three and a half minute
archery highlight
i gotta get in there i gotta get on the
peacock and start watching the
the rich archery highlights by the way
it's terrible gold and it's daily here
on uh peacock by the way because the
thing with your gail thing too
is it makes you if you're an announcer
or a broadcaster kind of want to talk
like this
i i didn't do you know that that goes
all the way
that goes way back i mean howard cosell
with the voice he always had like the
sports voice that i thought well when
he's just sitting around having a beer
he can't
talk like this you know what i mean like
what is the
vocal contortion of presentational
commentary you know that's what that's
what john michael higgins and i are
always trying to emulate
oh my god and we love it and as you know
that movie is on repeat
in my house yeah really weekly monthly
let's talk about my body my podcast
because i do love this because
you know i did the lakers podcast
podcasts are fun you can sit in your
pajamas you can interview somebody they
think you're dressed and ready to go and
you're really just your feet are up in
your living room table but
i love the idea that you're finally
doing one because it's something that
means something to you
so why my body my podcast
you know i i've been approached to do a
podcast and i thought
i want to do something more
autobiographical i wanted to tell us
i wanted to tell stories honestly and i
wanted to talk about
formative moments in my life
that i felt um were relatable to
everyone across
like it just doesn't matter when it
happened to you and it
turns out you know actors we have to
meet new people all the time every job
is new every set of people is new
you very rarely go to the same set you
know unless you're on a television show
for a long time but it's not my
experience yet you're constantly
interacting with new people and you have
to get
deep with those people fast and you have
to
bond and trust them really fast
and so ultimately you almost always end
up telling what i like to call
uh i actually piss poop and vomit
stories
okay um can i say those words on your
show stay down here i did butt hugger on
the show yesterday
okay great so um but also it's a lot of
it is like
your your puberty stories like your
first times you know and what i realized
in telling
and doing that storytelling is and and
bringing people into that tent i've
always
and as you know because i'm one of your
girlfriends your gal pals
i'm very open with all that stuff and i
would say that this is the most personal
thing i've ever done as an artist
because it's very much about
storytelling
bringing people into a conversation
versus
the podcast where it's like you
interview somebody about you know their
first time or this or that the other i
just felt like i wanted to almost
create something that was like chapters
of a book and take advantage
of the very personal nature of podcasts
you're in someone's ear
and you're inviting them into a
conversation
things that things that i've spoken to
my best girls
about for years and years and years i
thought
can other people relate to this and can
we um invite them into this conversation
and talk about
very taboo subject matter
which i think
helps people lead a better life
so one of the main themes of the podcast
is that
our sex sexuality gender all those
things
they're very siloed off by our culture
but in fact they are part of our
holistic
long-term health
mental physical everything like our
like your your pleasure your loves
your physical body um your sense of
safety
all of that uh matters to your long term
we talk to especially kids and friends
about
uh everything but that stuff you never
ask about like
what's going on in the bedroom you know
or what how are you doing with
menopause or how you doing with your
period like
no one says period on like you know
podcasts and so
i was like well i want to do i want to
talk about that stuff
so yeah of course i do and i just wanna
i just
it's all about uh stigma and taking it
away from all those
topics and so i offer a lot of my own
personal experiences
and then talk to a lot of experts about
how they either
messed me up or contributed to my
ongoing
happiness and mental health i'm curious
about whether it's more important for
you to do this because you are the
mother of two boys
too and i know how you are about raising
them to be
men and boys but sensitive to their role
in society and how they look at women
absolutely i felt like you know i have a
10 year old and eight year old
and i know you know this from your kids
too like puberty is
it's around the corner and i am not
prepared yep and i
i i realized that i was not prepared and
i thought how do i
arm myself with some tools and how do i
explore what happened to me at those
ages
um and and really and be honest about it
you know be honest about like being a
sexual being
young and early and and being aware of
things younger and earlier and
the internet is not making our job any
easier it's only making our job harder
and it really felt to me
uh that this was something that i could
do not just for myself
but to become a better mom and to become
a better human and to understand sort of
what the landscape was going to look
like for me and talking to my kids so i
really got some incredibly valuable
tools
to take forward and that i want to bring
into my community too i mean
with all of my relationships i all i've
been talking about now it's like
uh you know boys are you know looking up
there might won't be watching sports but
they're also watching porn are we all
clear on this like when this is
happening and what's going on and
how do we get ahead of it you know and
not and be shame free
about everything that's happening too
because that to me is the most important
thing is how do we talk about it without
stigma and shame
elizabeth banks joining me here on the
rich eisen show my body my podcast
available on audible on july 29th
i would be remiss before you go it is
today the 20th anniversary of wet hot
american summer
just says any idea what you were getting
into
when you showed up for that movie you
know we wanted to make a cult classic
because we were all obsessed with
richard linklater
and we were obsessed with uh fast times
of ridgemont high and we were
you know we were just we wanted to make
that we thought like this is a
coming-of-age story that could be like a
cult classic
and i mean it was so culty that like
four people saw it when it came out
but 20 years on it is in fact a cult
classic
so we did accomplish the thing i i think
that we
all hoped we were going to do which is
kind of amazing when's the last time you
saw it
the original yeah oh my gosh
i've seen pieces of it i have not
watched it you know
head to tail uh in a very long time
bananas think about it it's bradley
cooper in his first movie
me me and bradley our first movie yeah
it's your first movie too
yeah bradley and i is our first movie
met on that movie
amy poehler paul rudd but you know even
janine garofalo and david hyde pierce
and molly shannon who are were all
like names then um
it was i remember when we were making
the movie that paul rudd who had done
clueless and
and i think he'd been like a guest on
friends a little bit but it wasn't like
happening yet he got to be on the cover
of
interview magazine and we we all
bought it and we like put pictures that
we put the cover up like everywhere like
we were so happy and jealous and excited
and like all the feelings of like oh my
god paul like
you're making it you know and i remember
he was like i think i'm
i think he went to asia to do like a
kung fu movie or something my life
wasn't even in english
like it's like i can't really get a job
and now he's paul ryan he's a man it is
what it is so
we could see it was really fun to see it
happening like then you know amy getting
snl and like just being able to root for
people 80 miles who's in the movie you
know he
ended up being the head writer of jimmy
fallon for years
so these guys were they're they were all
not to mention david wayne and michael
show walter and mike lee and black who
were
um obviously icons especially in new
york because of
because of um everything they had done
and
their sketch comedy and stella and the
whole thing so
it's been a really fun ride i wonder if
you could even make that movie today
i hope so i mean i think you can
definitely make movies that feel
culty and exciting um
and and you know we're always i'm always
trying to discover really cool new
people i mean pitch perfect was a bunch
of unknowns anna kendrick was the only
name in the entire movie we
we cast around her and and found a bunch
of
you know unlikely heroines and i think
that is possible
people love to discover new talent and
they like to root for underdogs and that
is what was at the heart of what had
american summer
so it's great the timing was perfect i'm
thrilled to plug the podcast because i
think it's so important and
come home already i'm kind of gone
forever
but uh when you get back we're gonna
crack some archer roos
yes watch what a hot american summer all
right thank you i love you
i love you guys i love rich too i hope
he's having fun talking about tokyo
gold tokyo gold everybody i think you
have to see the word everybody after it
because it just feels a lot better
it just feels a lot better i'll take a
link a lot of press
though for the americans to actually
have the most gold
right well yeah because it's american to
have more
yeah we need the most we have to
actually be the winningest
so i don't know i'm suddenly like
currently today we're not leading in the
metal tally but i'm sure soon enough
will be tokyo gold 24 7. well tune in to
tokyo gold tomorrow on peacock and
you'll see rich eisen do a 75 minute
archery highlight
it'll be great yes that'll be my it's my
audition for
pitch perfect 7. just so you know all
right i'm gonna be a kid
say hi to max love you too babe i can't
wait to actually see you in person
kisses kisses
you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here